[Musique]
monsieur zemmour à chaque fois que je
l'entends lui fait c'est un discours
sur toujours le déclin de la france il
fait partie de ceux qui misent sur
déclin du pays il faut que ils
réfléchissent à ne pas être un trublion
qui ferait perdre un candidat avec un
vrai projet avec une vraie chance de
l'emporter manier des idées sur un
plateau c'est bien tenir le manche
conduire le camion du pays
je n'oublie tout de suite c'est tout à
fait différent selon un récent sondage
au premier tour le polémiste si faudrait
des voix à marine le pen qui passerait
sous la barre des 20% mais du côté du
rassemblement national on relativise les
grignote autour du récent nationale et
la candidature de marine le pen mais
aussi de monsieur dupont-aignan aussi
des républicains donc calé adversaire
d'exams ours et la question qu'ils
soient qui se formule est ce qu'il est
l'allié des mails macro et donc du
système actuel dit d' aventure on a fait
un second tour emmanuel macron eric
zemmour est ce que vous diriez la même
chose je côtoyais dont je voterai riggs
et bourg très clairement quand on est
prétendument candidats à la primaire
d'un parti qui s'appelle les
républicains on se garde bien de faire
la promotion de quelqu'un qui est un
délinquant multirécidiviste condamné à
plusieurs reprises pour un fait qui en
france n'est pas une opinion mais un
délit et notamment le racisme voilà 8e
samedi de manifestations anti passe et
une mobilisation en baisse cent quarante
mille personnes dans les rues de france
hier des anti vaccins qui persiste une
mobilisation une nouvelle fois en baisse
puisqu'il ya une semaine ils étaient 160
mille quelques défilés ont été émaillés
d'incidents vingt-et-une personnes ont
été interpellées dont trois à paris ce
qui est nouveau cette fois-ci ce sont
ces échauffourées qui ont éclaté
notamment dans le quartier des halles
les manifestants sont échappés d'un
détachée d'un cortège ils ont tenté
d'envahir le centre commercial des
halles à châtelet la police est
intervenue pour voiliers semble-t-il
effectué une manoeuvre pour les faire
sortir de
justement de chute le pass sanitaire
fait partie des armes que nous avons
pour lutter contre la pandémie s'il n'y
avait pas le pas solitaire d'alternative
c'est quoi la fermeture complète vous
l'avez dit vous l'avez connu on l'a
connu bon alors le pas sanitaire c'est
un progrès on a une 4ème vague qui
évolue favorablement puisqu'on a baissé
de 20% le nombre de cas en une semaine
donc ça c'est un élément important même
si la situation vous savez restent très
difficiles dans les outre-mers messieurs
castex devient fou messieurs castex n'a
aucune stratégie de santé publique
messieurs castex en novembre 2020 se
rendait dans un centre hospitalier en
disant aux aides soignants je sais vous
allez souffrir mais je sais que vous
allez souffrir c'est pas une stratégie
politique de santé publique il tranche
avec l'image du rebelle en sandales et
turbans
filmé ici hier par la télévision
chinoise sur l'aéroport de kaboul les
forces spéciales talibane l'unité badri
313 aux etats unis le secrétaire d'état
aux transports pittsburgh ayez a choisi
la transparence sur sa vie privée avec
son mari de chasse ten il vient d'avoir
des jumeaux et les deux paires pose avec
joseph et pénélope dans les bras cette
unité qui tire son nom d'une bataille
légendaire du prophète mahomet serait
très expérimenté après plus de 15 ans de
combat contre les américains elle est
aussi la mieux équipée avec son armement
made in us est saisie à l'armée
régulière afghane lorsque celle ci a
littéralement rendu les armes impression
de fin du monde en louisiane à grande
île
l'ouragan ida y avait commencé mercredi
sa course meurtrière
des dizaines de maisons détruites et 47
victimes aux états unis
[Musique]
cette image satellite cette fois à l'est
dans le new-jersey avant le passage de
la tempête
le même lieu aujourd'hui souvent